let's your wife beat heads like this has  a neural implant  but to bring up that last memory and see  what their prom right booting up now how  are they awake get them back under  good morning lieutenant  and wait this isn't right this isn't the  simulation I know that this isn't some  glitch as some sort of virus has  infiltrated our system and more bad news  intent  remember that thing about damage here  not being real yeah not so much  [Music]  and you're both here great that isn't  weird off  you need to keep them away from the life  support programs lieutenant you really  need to hurry I don't think I keep  hearing someone something moving around  out here  heaven's sake it's like walking with a  child  [Music]